in this video you're going to learn how
to graph quadratic inequalities and
we're going to be graphing systems which
means we involves two or more of these
quadratic inequalities we're going to go
through two examples together so let's
dive into the first example now when
you're graphing these uh quadratic
inequalities these are parabas and
remember there's three different forms
here that we can work with we can work
with this general form here the vertex
form and the intercept form and we'll
talk about that as we go through this
lesson so you can see this first
inequality is in the vertex form and we
can see that our vertex is at H comma K
remember that the number here this group
with the X it has the opposite effect on
the graph so minus two means it's
actually going to shift it to the right
to the plus4 that has the same effect
it's going to shift it up four so if we
go right to up four that's our vertex
that's where the graph bends now notice
that the a value is -1 so that negative
means that it's going to be open putting
downward like this and notice we have
less than or equal to if it's equal to
it's going to be a solid line if it's
less than or greater than but not equal
to then it's going to be a dashed or a
dotted line so here we have equal to
it's going to be solid what you can do
though is it remember Parabola is they
symmetric about that vertex about that
uh axis of symmetry that line that goes
through the vertex so by picking some
points on either side we can get a good
sketch of our graph so for example if I
put uh one in 1 - 2 is 1 1^ 2 is 1 * a
netive is 1 + 4 is 3 so that means we're
going to have a point right here and if
I reflect that over the axis of symmetry
we have another point there if I put
zero in I get -2 s is 4 * a negative is
-4 + 4 is 0o and I can reflect that over
that line of symmetry here at xal 2 and
you can keep doing that getting some
more points but here you can see our
graph's going to look something like
this
and now the question is is it's an
inequality where do we shade do we shade
on this part of the plane or on this
other side of that graph above the
parabola well you can do this two
different ways when it's less than you
can think about shading below and that
only works if the Y is by itself here on
the left like the Y values are less than
that means like y controls the vertical
Direction up and down so less means
below so I could just say if I pick a
point here on the graph and I shade
below below below you see that's going
to be basically uh on the inside here of
this Parabola some students don't like
that method they like to use what they
call the test Point method and you could
pick a point say for example I picked
the point uh one one right here if I
plug one in for x and one in for y let's
do that right now we're going to put a
little question mark here uh-1 - 2 is
going to be 1 okay now let's see if this
is true we get
1- 1 + 4 is 3 so is 1 less than or equal
Al to three yes that's true so that test
Point 1 one since that was true that's
the side of the graph that we want to
shade if it's false we would shade on
the other side so I kind of like to just
think of Y is by itself less than is
below and greater than is above but you
can use this test Point method so for
here you can see we're going to be
graphing something like this I'll just
draw some lines here we're on that part
of the graph for the second quadratic
here you can see this is in the
basically in this general form right
here and the B value the number in front
of the X that's zero since we don't have
an X term so you can use the formula if
you want B over 2 a in this case b is
zero so we'd say 0 over 2 * 12 which is
still zero so that means the x
coordinate of our vertex is going to be
zero if we plug that back in you can see
that Y is going to be -2 so our vertex
is at 0 -2 which is right here and again
remember parabas they're Sy about that
that line of symmetry that goes right
through the vertex so if I was to pick
some other points like say for example
if I was to pick maybe like uh -2 a -2 ^
2 is 4 * a half is 2 minus 2 is zero so
right here I would be at zero and if I
reflect that over right there's another
one now I can pick some more points but
let's just uh notice that this is
greater than but not equal to so this is
going to be a dashed or dotted line if
it was equal to then it would
be
solid okay and then now notice that the
Y over here is on the left y values are
greater than this greater than means
it's above now if it was less than it
would be shading below sometimes what I
like to do if I know I'm on this side
here of this Parabola I like to draw the
lines so that when you see the
overlapping region it's like a
cross-hatched uh type region you can see
here they're like double overlapped so
then I would go back and I would darken
this region in okay so it's basically
right
here is where they're they're
overlapping and you can use colored
pencils and so you know that sometimes
helps yellow and blue you know makes
green or uh you know whatever you choose
but sometimes making one of them
vertical one of them horizontal you can
see where they're cross-hatched let's
take a look at another
example okay let's dive into example
number two now we've got the first
quadratic inequality notice that this is
in the intercept form see how it's like
factored so when it's in this intercept
or factored form by setting these uh
factors equal to zero we can find the x
intercept so if I set x + 3 equal to 0
we're going to get x = -3 is our x
intercept and if we set X - 1 equal to 0
we're going to get xal 1 is our x
intercept now knowing that parabas are
symmetric what we can do is we can find
the midpoint between these two x
intercepts so you could do that either
by just adding them together and
dividing by two kind of like your
midpoint formula or like an average
that's going to come out to 2 over two
which is equal to one uh sorry negative
1 okay so then what that means is at
negative 1 that's our axis of symmetry
the vertex lies on that axis of symmetry
so if we take the negative one we put it
back in for X we can get the
corresponding y-coordinate of the vertex
so let's do that- 1 + 3 is
21 - 1 is
-2 and you can see this comes out to8 so
our vertex is going to be here at
-18 which is right about there so you
can see we have a pretty good sketch
already so this is equal to so it's
going to be a
solid line if it was less than or
greater than but not equal to it would
be a dotted now if I want to find out
where crosses the the y- axis I could
put zero in for X that's going to come
out to -6 so it's going to cross right
here and get a little B bit better
sketch right okay so you can see that's
our Parabola and notice that Y is less
than or equal to which means we're
shading
below this Parabola right or if you
don't like that method you could do the
test point a good test point is the
origin 0 0 if I put zero in for x and
zero in for y let's see what we get we
get I'll just put a little question mark
here this comes out to
three and this comes out to
ne-1 and you can see is 0 less than or
equal to -6 well
uh no Z is actually greater than all the
negative numbers so where this origin
point is 0 0 is false you'd want to
shade on the other side of the parabola
which coincides with what we talked
about earlier less than we're shading
below so let's just go ahead and do that
I'm going to I'm going to just draw line
straight down like that less than we
think about the Y controlling the
vertical Direction up and down less than
is below this is just one way to to do
it and then if we look at the second
quadratic uh inequality
uh you can see that this is in the
general form this ax2 plus BX plus C
form and we can use our B over 2A to
find that Axis of Symmetry and the x
coordinate of the vertex that's going to
be the opposite of-4 which is
4 over 2 * a which is 1 so we have 4
over 2 which is two now if you put two
back in we get 4 - 8 which is -4 - 2
which is -6 so that's our vertex here at
26 right about here that's our axis of
symmetry and we can pick some points on
either side so for example if I was to
put in a a one that would give us 1 - 4
is-3 - 2
is5 and I can reflect that and if I put
in zero I get -2 and I can reflect that
and notice this is greater than but not
equal to which means this is a dashed or
a dotted line so I'm just going to kind
of eye this here a little bit now again
you can plot more points it be a little
bit more accurate okay um now notice
this graph y is greater than greater
than means we're shading above right so
that means if I pick this point above
above above but what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to draw these lines
horizontally so that I can hopefully uh
illustrate for us a little bit more
clearly since we're just using black a
black pen pen or marker here so we can
see where they overlap so do you see
where it's like cross hased how do you
say that hatched or hashed hashed right
so basically it looks like they're um
they're double overlapped right in this
region right here so if we were to go
back and darken
this it's like that so basically you're
below the one Parabola above the other
Parabola you're looking at where they
overlap and it's going to be right in
that region so great if you're able to
follow these couple examples here if you
want more practice I'll put a video
right there talking more about how to
graph these quadratic inequalities
follow me over there and test yourself
get some more practice I'll see you over
in that video